the dial-up internet this reminded me
when I was a kid yeah
and you might not have had ever sent
messenger but I'm guessing you're the
MSN Messenger generation right like that
was my uni year that's how we were
communicating I've got obsessive it you
cannot pray an emissary name what would
you do you might dress me for your
characters new [ __ ] Oh III
I love command the dark and stormy oh
that sounds like he comes from webcam
blue [ __ ] sorry
[Music]
walkabout sky with me Josh Smith and
today we're joined by the bad boy and a
bad girl from Captain Marvel it's
jamming June now what I loved about this
was the 90s bro back I was taken back
who know those massive mobile phones
what is the 190s trend you wish you'd
let go of sooner and which is the one
you would love to resurrect well I love
that bum bags are back love ya I love my
fury bum bag I hadn't the nineties
darlin why would you not want to have
for your bits and pieces here yeah from
we've been talking shell C solo I never
rocked a shell suit this yeah I mean I
wore a shell see that I had you might
but you know you did then discover that
they're really flammable and I was being
sent to that bonfire nice but no hands
yeah you I'm fired up now speaking of
nineties i comest you to borrow your
inner Scary Spice
I found this quite badass a little spicy
where do you go to to bring out the
badass within Geri Halliwell clearly and
that's kind of great we're here are
warriors because you'll come like blue a
birdie bar avid I've another thank you
but yeah we really gotta get in there
and it took like four hours to get that
makeup on right so what's like the
Nisha's thing you've done to pass the
time in that situation part of Emma so
easy oh god there's not much you can do
you cannot sleep because you get woken
up by cold jet severe in various
orifices you can't listen to things she
can't have earbuds in yeah I mean he had
it easy rocking up to work like four
hours off hmm I'm really sorry about
that like genuine I hadn't apologized
yet I wasn't in on the decision-making I
was told I wasn't blue but those suits
look kind of happy to be honest they
can't be that breezy
the suits took a lot of planning because
toilet breaks yeah when to take
coordinate right so it's good from a lot
of control basically very good to learn
to use your ladder prop so you can as n
landing after all this guy how long have
I got another two hours I can do it
there's also the soundtrack while there
is popping yeah I mean tail see
waterfalls yeah yeah yeah I was like
swaying in a cinema artist I said that
fillers show and I was like dude I don't
believe it she was sort of breezed past
like yeah that's like the best moment
when it does pans right as that's on the
radio yeah if you two are gonna be
international DJs which I feel like
could be really good doing that's timing
this veteran dark and Stormies serving
up the risers right there what would
your top 90s track speed I'm what we the
moves you'll be getting down to
brainstorm interlude by the that's an
awesome - yeah
Lauryn Hill
yeah I'm Joseph it steps on there too I
mean get a real 90s classic in man yep
yeah yeah I'm not sure about I take the
club guys thanks very much
[Applause]